c'est sous la pluie que se sont
retrouvés président premier ministre
ministre et invités de marque à gênes
pour inaugurer le pont genoa à san
giorgio construit en un temps record en
moins de deux ans le pont vient
remplacer le pont morandi qui s'est
effondré le 14 ou 2018 fauchant au
passage 43 vie les familles des victimes
de l'effondrement était d'ailleurs
absente aujourd'hui préférant rencontré
le président matar est là en aparté les
cérémonies aux couleurs de l'italie
avait les airs déplacer d'une
célébration pour elle le nom de chacun
des disparus a été lu et on a observé
une minute de silence en leur mémoire
et christopher fil de notre jeu ce pont
est née de la tragédie et de la douleur
on ne peut pas les oublier a dit
l'architecte du projet en rendant
hommage aux victimes
twitter c'est une véritable course
contre la montre avec des équipes qui se
sont relayés 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7 qui a permis d'effacer en moins de
deux ans la cicatrice d'une plaie qui a
fait souffrir et indigne et l'italie
entière
la crise du coronavirus a à peine
ralenti le chantier s'il fallait faire
aussi vite c'est que pour la ville de
gênes le pont représente un lien vital
depuis la catastrophe l'agglomération
tout entière était au bord de l'asphyxié
gène est construite dos à la montagne et
face à la mer des défenses naturelles
formidable à une époque qui aujourd'hui
isole la métropole de huit cent mille
habitants
dès le 5 ou le pont san giorgio sera
ouvert au grand public restaurants dans
son sillage un axe commercial important
entre l'italie et la france
la justice elle pour les familles des
victimes avancent moins vite que le
béton et l'acier
plusieurs dirigeants de la compagnie est
l'entière responsable de l'opération et
l'entretien du pont morand d'eau font
face à de possibles accusations
d'homicide involontaire
un procès devrait s'ouvrir l'an prochain
ici marie ève bédard radio-canada paris